but this is the crazy part about this  story at the time two chains is the  hottest [ __ ] in the world they telling  Two Chains he got a play before me and  two changes looking at me like are you  really about to do this but you know me  I'm in my own I'm I'm feeling myself so  two chains played before me  then I had to go on after this  [ __ ] hit me in the head with a limit  and I'm so stage I thought I blocked it  I started let me come and I swiped at it  but I was like yeah y'all seen that I  hit the limit trying to be cooling from  the crowd but then we watched the  playback the [ __ ] beamed my whole [ __ ]  Two Chains maybe like sitting like over  there he's looking at me we both lock  eyes and this is [ __ ] said stupid